in tonight's whatever happened to
segment efforts to recover an American
Marine turned journalist kidnapped by
terrorists in Syria here's chief
correspondent Jonathan hunt first thing
in the morning last thing at night all
day long this Mother's Day as she does
every day Debra Tice will be thinking of
her son Austin I pray for him
to be strengthened and comfort and that
his captors will you know treat him
humanely Austin Tice served in
Afghanistan as a Marine then became a
journalist and was working in Syria when
he was kidnapped in August 2012 this
disturbing video was the last the world
saw of Austin whose compassion was
vividly displayed recently at his alma
mater Georgetown University in an
exhibition of his photos of Syrian
children his parents as well as the US
government which is offering a million
dollar reward for information leading to
Austin's safe return are sure he's alive
I have always been 100% confident
Austin's alive he's he's living in
captivity
you know we're sure he wants to come
home and get his freedom back and and
that's what we want mark and Debra Tice
also say there's been a new more
aggressive approach since President
Trump took office and for the first time
they revealed the president made them a
promise when they met him in March he's
ever gonna get him home and that has
been the response from everyone in the
White House and in the administration
that we've talked to they're committed
to bringing him home so I mean you can't
ask for more than that from your own
government what's the first thing you're
gonna do
I give him a big hug whooping holler
yeah and Mark and Deborah also told us
that in the tradition of the theis
family Austin's six siblings plan to
give him a pretty hard time as
punishment for the trouble he's caused
them here's hoping they get that chance
very soon